all right joining us now with more
reaction the author of a brand new uh
explainer for the US Constitution and
other patriotic documents amazon.com
hannity.com bookstores around the
country Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett along with Harvard Law Professor
Alan dtz and former acting us attorney
uh General Matt Whitaker you know this
loan part or promiser no part is less
impressive to me uh because if there's
paperwork if there was a loan that would
be perfectly legal legitimate I'm
assuming Matt Whitaker the issue to me
is is what what it what we have now
found and discovered and we are hearing
from James comr that there all these
suspicious activity reports all of these
shell corporations they've identified
all of these tens of millions of dollars
that the Biden family members were
receiving um including grandchildren the
money seems to be shuffled from company
to company but the companies don't seem
to have any real purpose they're not
providing any goods or services that we
can ascertain the question is why was
this family being paid tens of millions
of dollars and and seemingly we can find
no work that they offered in exchange
for that then you go to Deon Archer's
testimony which is number one Joe Biden
did talk to the foreign business
partners of Hunter at least 20 times
that he knows of we know about the
meetings at Cafe Milano
and and then the question becomes uh you
know was this access you know was this
to pay uh to play for Access here
especially if we you cannot identify any
services
rendered yeah Sean this is a really good
way for the Biden family to support
itself because you see the people that
are getting the loans the people that
are getting the money the people that
are the beneficiaries of all these llc's
and all these wire transfers all are in
the Biden family and and this is how Joe
it appears figured out how to take care
of his family and on a meager salary of
a senator of a vice president and now
president you know you can't support all
of these folks but what you can do is
you can have structure these
transactions have your son and your
brother out there that are conducting
business because of their relationship
with you and their their familial
relationship with you and so it is very
clear to me that if this you know we
would call this organized crime in any
other context but the Biden family
business and that's what concerns me the
most is that this is exactly the way
organized crime has structured their
deals and this uh lack of curiosity by
the Department of Justice is is
incredibly disappointing to say the
least but it's you know at some point in
time this entire story is going to be
revealed and it is disgusting all right
let's get your take Professor dwoods
here look do do can we identify any
services rendered for the money that
James comr the house oversight committee
is talking about here cuz they're
talking about tens of millions of
dollars I don't see any services
rendered do
you no and if they were he wouldn't be
qualified to render them uh there are
two big questions number one does the
special counsil for Hunter Biden have
jurisdiction Beyond Hunter Biden that
would extend to the president of the
United States and if not there ought to
be a special Council appointed to
investigate Beyond Hunter Biden the
hunter Biden part of it is only a small
part look John Solomon is a great
investigative reporter I have found that
his conclusions are almost always
validated and there's enough smoke here
to appoint a really distinguished
outside of the justice department not
somebody who was in the Justice
Department special special counsel to
look at the relationship between Hunter
Biden Joseph Biden Joseph Biden's
brother the entire family I'm a Democrat
I hope they clear him if I would Jo
Biden I would want a special counsel CU
there's so much smoke but the American
public has the right to an investigation
not done by the justice department and
not done by republicans in Congress but
done by a special independent person who
has great integrity we want to know the
truth okay but the problem is I don't
believe we've had that Greg Jared uh
David Weiss I mean we had the
conflicting he he even was conf uh
conflicted him self he gave one story to
Lindsey Graham one story to Jim Jordan
about whether he had authority to bring
charges in jurisdictions like DC in
California so then of course he becomes
special counsel but he's also the guy
that let that let the statute of
limitations pass uh we now know Robert
uh her in in fact is not going to pursue
any charges on the issue of top secret
classified documents and that Joe
Biden's only going to get a Stern lect
just like Hillary got away with it but
they raid Mara Lago so I'm not sure that
that Joe Biden's justice department is
capable of appointing the type of
special prosecutor that Professor dtz is
referring to oh I I don't trust them at
all particularly David R Weiss I think
he's part of the protection racket run
by merri Garland and to some extent the
FBI for the bidens uh you know the news
broke yesterday that uh there is Weiss
has convened a grand jury in Los Angeles
Southern California Central District um
looking into potential tax evasion and
and tax fraud apparently ignoring money
laundering pharoh violations and bribery
statutes but
nevertheless this strikes me as a
potential charade by David Weiss I mean
this is the guy who tore up an agreement
uh to bring six serious felony charges
against Hunter Biden gave him immunity
in a sweetheart plea deal it was only a
federal judge that forced him to bring
the gun charges and it appears that
Congress by uncovering incriminating
evidence has forced his hand to convene
a grand jury uh in California but you
know I'm not fooled by this uh you know
a grand jury is secret if a guy like
Weiss as the prosecutor presents
apathetic case and feeble evidence uh
and doesn't push for an indictment and
in fact fact stands idly by and doesn't
say one way or another or not so subtly
tells the grand jurors don't Indi like a
ham sandwich you know they won't indict
uh and so this strikes me as a potential
farce here and window dressing so he can
say oh gee I tried but it was those
grand
jurors exit question same question for
all three of you on a scale of 1 to
10 um based on all we know about Joe Li
in never talked to his son brother
anybody for that matter about foreign
business deals knowing this testimony
that in fact he participated in calls
knowing about barisma knowing about the
WhatsApp message how much legal trouble
is Joe Biden likely in scale to 1 to 10
Matt
Whitaker I think he has very low
exposure to any criminal uh culpability
but certainly he has a lot of political
liability right now what about
impeachment scale of 1 to
10 I think it's pretty high I was just
with chairman Smith today I think they
are doing a deliberate uh investigation
and they're going to have the goods uh
to impeach before you know this Congress
ends profession Professor
sorry here's my idea let the house
Judiciary Committee controlled by
Republicans give the justice department
a list of 10 names of special counsel
Democrats and Republicans
nonpartisan and let the Attorney General
pick from that list of 10 names trust
he'll never do it ever not this just not
this AG he's been
politicized have a special counsel here
I think the odds on impeachment here are
zero but the odds on some kind of
criminal liability are you know a three
or four I'd like to reduce it to a zero
but I want to see a real independent
some some former College hear what
you're
saying I don't think that's going to
happen all right we got to get to Greg
Greg last you get the last word the
record is repl with instances of Joe
Biden aiding and abetting the influence
pedaling schemes of his son the media
misses the point when they say oh no
money went to Joe it doesn't have to
look it up 18 USC 2011 if you confer a
benefit in exchange for money to another
person or entity other than your
yourself that is a crime 1 to 10 legal
liability impeachment liability well
legal liability with the Department of
Justice next to zero uh I agree it's a
pretty high probability on impeachment
all right I think you have the right
answer Professor dtz I know your heart's
in the right place not with this
attorney general he that that department
has been weaponized sadly sad to say hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else